So the mode is a useful statistic
if your distribution of data is what is called multimodal.
In multimodal distributions, you have a curve that has multiple bumps.
This one is called bimodal
because it has exactly 2 bumps.
The mode is the highest value of the largest bump,
which now occurs here with the value of 4.
So in a situation like this, the mean is usually irrelevant,
It falls just between the data.
as we showed with our house prices example.
The median may be in the middle or flipped from left to right
and really doesn't say much either.
The mode, too, can flip from left to right.
At the very least, it corresponds to something that is very frequent in the data.
So for bimodal data, or for multimodal data,
which is data with even more than two bumps,
the mode is something you should really calculate.
So let's practice.
So let me give you a list of numbers: 5, 9, 100, 9, 97, 6, 9, 98, and 9.
Compute for me the three Ms: mean, median, and mode.